Elon Musk appeared at Twitter's
California headquarters as his 44
billion dollar takeover of the social
media platform was beginning to sink in
musk who'd already changed his Twitter
title to Chief twit confirmed the news
and you guessed it a tweet on Friday
morning
but it's how free the bird will be that
is of most concern to users his first
move was to fire CEO parag agrawal and
top executives
it's no secret that the Tesla CEO thinks
there's far too much censorship on
Twitter there are concerns amongst
people that I spoke to that people or
accounts that have engaged in
disinformation or misinformation or
forms of harassment or bullying may be
allowed to stay on a platform in a way
that they previously have not musk
previously said he'd reinstate former
president Donald Trump who was banned in
the wake of the January 6 riots Trump
responded on his own social media
platform Friday that he was happy
Twitter is quote now insane hands but
musk announced plans to form a Content
moderation Council saying no major
content decision or account
reinstatements would happen before they
met and appealing to advertisers musk
tweeted that Twitter obviously cannot
become a free-for-all hellscape where
anything can be said with no
consequences musk has pledged follow the
law of the land but that is a concern in
authoritarian countries where Twitter
has historically resisted calls to take
down anti-government tweets
some of those rules are going to mean
that people in certain countries are
going to have a very locked down version
of Twitter whilst others are going to
have a much more freewheeling experience
it's going to be a Minefield for him to
operate
I'm nine years as a publicly traded
company on
is removed from the stock market on
November 8th the first official step to
going private while some employees were
terminated on Friday musk has pushed
back against reports that he planned to
cut 75 percent of Staff but he has not
denied that big changes are ahead
Kristin salumi Al Jazeera New York